job dating stand d'orientation rencontre
avec des organismes de formation et
découverte des métiers du numérique
de nombreux ateliers se sont installés
au pied du quartier le val-fourré à
mantes-la-jolie
l'idée pour pôle emploi allaient à la
rencontre directe des jeunes des
quartiers prioritaires de la ville
c'est important pour pôle emploi parce
que ça permet aussi de savoir ce dont
ils ont besoin et donc nous en termes
d'accompagnement parle beaucoup
d'accompagnement personnalisé donc le
fait de connaître leurs attentes ça
permet aussi à nos conseillers d'adapter
de l'accompagnement qu'ils ont à faire
avec eux nous est venus pour trouver un
emploi ou une formation
il a déjà trouvé quelques entreprises
qui peuvent l'intéresser
c'est important parce que je suis
monsieur arrêta mon bac et il faut en
fait financer mon permis tout ça et du
père lui aussi ça où beaucoup de ça ou
des portes pour trouver un emploi
voilà c'est pour ça que c'est important
pour moi pour l'occasion
nadia et la ministre déléguée en charge
de la ville a rencontré des jeunes
présents sur place elle a participé à
une table ronde concernant l'orientation
et l'emploi des jeunes des quartiers
prioritaires
il existe pléthore de dispositifs que
kate qui sont mis en place et que nous
mettons davantage en place dans le cadre
du plan de relance mais qu'on
s'inscrivent aussi dans une logique de
parcours pour qu'on puisse trouver une
solution pour tous les habitants de nos
quartiers ou pour tous les jeunes dans
les yvelines au deuxième trimestre de
2020 le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi de
moins de 25 ans s'élève à plus de 9300
jeunes